growing up I was kind of always
self-conscious like wanting to look a
certain way it's a never-ending battle
you look at yourself and you know you
can never attain that ideal as I've
gotten older you see different changes I
feel like I have some wrinkles around my
eyes I'm never going to be skinny I'm
not a skinny girl it can be hard when
you see models and celebrities and like
you just don't look the same
you
okay Wow oh my god I did not expect it
to look like that at all I feel like it
doesn't even look like me I think cuz I
know myself
this looks really different why would
you want to make someone look so
different I like my freckles I think
they add character and the fact that
they're gone I don't even know who that
is just as a normal person seeing
yourself change and your identity
changed it's pretty pretty shocking
once someone else has done your makeup
and someone else has done your hair and
someone's directed the way your body
looks and then taking away your
imperfections then there's not much left
of who you really are this is how I
always wanted to see myself but now that
I see it I'm like questioning why I ever
wanted to look like that you look at
these ads in magazines you see these
women who look absolutely flawless and
you're like oh I wish I could look like
that but who really looks like this I
think we live in a really interesting
time where we feel like we have to make
people look to the standard that's not
attainable for anybody instead of
looking at other things and trying to
aspire to be something else we should
just be comfortable in who we are and
just try to be our best selves I think
something that everybody should keep in
mind is that it's natural to be critical
of yourself it's natural to be
uncomfortable or awkward but you just
have to know that the ideal just doesn't
exist